the talk of twitter right now is that
there are some people out there who are
saying absurd things to try to pin
bitcoin and cryptocurrency into a corner
to try to present it as some sort of act
of nefarious people the bad actors of
the demons of society what am i talking
about well yesterday this guy dave troy
came out and he literally said this this
is not a joke i'm not trying to uh
photoshop this this is a real tweet he
said i can't stress this enough the
crypto attack on the dollar is not
strictly a pump and dump or a grift it's
an ideologically driven attack on the
legitimacy of fiat currency the federal
reserve and the incumbent financial
system
it is the sequel to the january 6th
attack
i literally don't know how
those three sentences all ended up in
the same tweet
so let's take them one by one
i can't stress this enough the crypto
attack on the dollar is not strictly a
pump and dump or a grift
now in order to have a pump and dump
people would have to pump up the price
and then sell it
85
of bitcoin in circulation doesn't move
nobody's selling
there's no dumping
people are buying this and they're
storing it
60 of bitcoin hasn't moved in over a
year
people buy the asset to hold it for a
long period of time
so again
that can't be a pump and dump if nobody
sells
on top of that
if it was a grift
then why are the bitcoiners buying
bitcoin and holding it they're literally
putting their own money into it and then
holding it and they won't sell it to you
if dave came right now and asked
somebody to sell them their bitcoin for
68 000
every bitcoiner would give him the
middle finger
so how is it that it's a grip he can't
buy it from me for 68 000.
so again it makes no sense that sentence
just cross it out like if we were the
teacher f minus cross that whole
sentence out makes no sense second
sentence it's an ideologically driven
attack on the legitimacy of fiat
currency the federal reserve and the
incumbent financial system okay let's
take this one by one ideologically
driven attack uh it's math it's software
code it's literally free speech
so i don't know if you can consider free
speech an ideologically driven attack
i think that literally it's just
mathematics and uh that makes zero sense
second on the legitimacy of fiat
currency we literally sat here today we
did a two-hour special with a publicly
traded ceo who owns billions of dollars
of this and we talked about how this
literally makes the fiat currency
stronger
many people in the community believe
that it's not an attack on it
it is going to strengthen it so again to
say that you are uh attacking the
legitimacy of it
every single person is sitting here
talking about how they are actually
going to improve it stable coins for
example there's 70 billion dollars for
the stable coins 90 billion dollars
whatever it is
stable coins
those are dollars
they're quite literally making the
dollars more accessible
easier to use lower friction lower cost
higher yield
they're improving it
they're not attacking the legitimacy
they're actually making it better
so again strike that part out federal
reserve well
i don't know anybody who at this point
really thinks that they have uh any sort
of accuracy but again if you support the
dollar then you support the federal
reserve because the federal reserve's in
charge of monetary policy so i don't
think you can say anyone's attacking the
legitimacy of them we may disagree but
guess what i disagree with my brother
doesn't mean i'm attacking his
legitimacy and he disagrees with me
doesn't mean he's attacking my
legitimacy
but it still means that the dollar is
being put forward in a better position
and then the incumbent financial system
you're right
paul tudor jones stanley drucken miller
fidelity sky bridge uh who else um wells
fargo bank of america jpmorgan chase uh
all the people who are going and buying
bitcoin who are investing in it or
helping their clients get access to it
etc they're all eating themselves
what
there's literally
etfs how are we attacking the legacy
financial system we're improving it
and the legacy players are participating
many would argue that some of these
assets and some of these products and
services are actually furthering the
legacy financial system to be more and
more powerful one of the critiques could
be that the financialization of this
asset is actually bad because it gives
more legitimacy more power to the legacy
financial system
okay
and then january 6th i mean i just i'll
just let that one stand there by itself
uh that it pretty absurd um and so when
we look at this
i think that the most important part
is that folks who disagree
on
the assets
they don't believe in free markets
what this gentleman appears to believe
is that there is some politicalization
of the asset as if there is two aisles
in politics or two sides of the aisle
and one side is wrong
they're essentially would i use the word
monetary terrorist
and they're attacking this other system
what are you talking about publicly
traded companies are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars that literally
interface with the legacy financial
system and are under the purview the
legacy financial system and regulators
are doing this
so again what we must do is we must
remember that bitcoin doesn't care about
politics it doesn't care what side of
the aisle you're on doesn't care frankly
about the legacy system at all it just
continues to produce block after block
after block after block of transactions
and when it produces block after block
after block after block of transactions
what it's saying is
this is math this is software code it's
free speech and we are immune to any
outside influence doesn't matter who you
are what organization you come from what
your beliefs are you are free to use the
bitcoin system whether you want to or
not is up to you but anyone has access
all you need is an internet connection
and that is really important because
we're moving to a world where everything
gets politicized
both sides of the aisle sling mud at
each other
who cares
let the adult children go play
instead there's a third solution now
it's more of a centrist view actually
that centrist view simply says that you
should be able to do what you want to do
here's a piece of technology if you want
to use it amazing you should go ahead
and use it you don't want to use it you
don't have to use it though
and that's the way that the world
probably should be and so i think that
this is really important to just call
out the fact that we cannot allow this
stuff to get politicized we cannot allow
this stuff to be pinned into some sort
of uh bifurcation or opposing view of
the legacy system
i don't think anyone's advocating for
the collapse legacy system instead what
they're saying is hey look at this new
thing this new thing actually is going
to be better
it's gold 2.0
gold has failed during high levels of
inflation
and the market is choosing this new
asset we should be celebrating that we
should actually be educating again we
should be educating every single citizen
the united states hey
you should be investing you should not
be sitting in dollars getting hit with
high levels of inflation